just said that now you said within
reason so that the whole point is that
your school is called compromising right
because if you came to me and I already
had my things set out for myself you'll
come and you're like stop cool you need
to come to me with something to make me
want to stop playing so basically the
guy has what kind of like monitor no let
me let me for example I was listening to
you like in terms of your relationship
with your man like and he came to you
and said I have this idea and if he came
to me on that kind of flex I'm not gonna
lie if I saw that Vision with you I
would I'm there with you but me I know
already started my thing I was single
before I was with you so I was doing
what I was doing and you came to me you
approached me
as you said guys approach the woman and
I went with it cool you know I wasn't
you met me I can compromise I can't
change I can't change